tale padre in cina lamentata perché stai
qui mi vuoi dire qualcosa specifiche
mancati da altissimo e quindi siamo
tornati con un nuovo video in cui
giocheremo sino al 10
beh penso che tutti sapete come funziona
il gioco di nascondino praticamente una
volta testa andremo a nascondersi quindi
devo nascondere il simbolo tornare con
noi dovremo andare a nascondersi e forse
da altra persona si trova questa evitare
vi trova un giorno d'oggi pokemon da
record io a cercare te in più c'è un
premio in palio 10 i botti passo stupito
vedere che per i bravi ma chi vince la
challenge vincerà tutti questi nuovi
switch water di globi andiamo subito a
vederli assieme dei muri spessi che
potete trovare in edicola e sono quindi
pedis crisci che hanno tipo l'acqua
dentro water squillo appunto verrete un
po questo penso che dovrebbe essere un
nuovo ma due palline dentro auguri già
aprirli sono super antistress
vediamo se rimbalzo
sembrava proprio un uovo fritto guarda
[Musica]
invece c'è anche il pesciolino benissimo
ma io vorrei aprirlo è proprio il peso
di oh wow bellissimo perché ma
spiattellare anche questo
[Musica]
e va beh sono fantastici sono super
antistress allora questi nuovi water
suisse switch del blog potete trovarli
in edicola costano 2 euro e 99 li
trovate in allegato al magazzino andiamo
a vedere il magazine
ecco qua mi raccomando richiedete sempre
il magazine esistono vari giochi e
immagini da onorare
quindi chi vincerà questa legge si
aggiudicherà a tutti gli scrissi
ovviamente spero di vincere io perché mi
piacciono un sacco dove poi questo pensi
veramente rai
vediamo chi è più bravo a nascondersi
fra noi due
poi noi alla fine del video dovrete
votare quale il sondaggio se ho vinto io
se ho vinto vitale va da chi è stato più
bravo a fondersi secondo me quello che
si nasconde meglio e berlino erano il
mago dei commenti spontini che vediamo
che inizia pratica lavori il sasso carta
forbice sacco forza obama carta poi
visitato
tu devi contare fino a denti 2 3 6 8 9
10 12 13 14 garlini c 17 18 19 20
possiamo andare dobbiamo a trovare anita
dovresti sarà nascosta sì 7 no
[Musica]
mi sento molto breve di berlino
quindi doveva dall'anica
[Musica]
ti sei nessun accordo con vita a farmi
scoprire prima ero piccolo tommy di
collaborare con me capita un po berlino
mi conosce il mio del bene grazie
ma aperto ti faccio mangiare uno di
quelli svizzeri appunto per vitale ora
tocca a me cercarti speriamo che il
netino con la gori con metodi girato da
un'altra parte e che tale fino a 20 con
la camera abbassata per non vedere dove
devo andare
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 dati ha chiuso la
porta così marinano lo segue non mi fa
sapere dov'è maledizione 13 14 15 pensi
di servette 18 baby berlino mi devi
aiutare andiamo trovare evitare ogni
anni stiamo brino andiamo video militare
con il tuo fiuto infallibile
andiamo dai berlino ma allora sei
proprio collaborando con vitale non con
me ma dovete ferendo un party e vabbè lo
troverò da sola
[Musica]
dietro un affare
ora tocca ora pari un berlino mi
raccomando eh collabora con berlino non
la vide seguire 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 13 15
17 18 19 24 arrivando
[Musica]
no
siamo due hanno fatto che a me conta
deve fare che cosa
[Musica]
un rumore marino perché se vi di fare ma
se si è nascosto quanto sono vitale
vecchio e milos è nascosto dai visi
nascosto ma che fai
vuoi mangiare lo chiama nuovamente
andiamo su un po di sale
berlino aiutami a trovarlo penso che sia
riuscito a berlino cosa stai combinando
linea di migliore dove perché guardi
soffitto 2
[Musica]
eppure mi sembrava di sentire dei rumori
qua dentro
[Musica]
berlino ma che fai in cui fossero piarda
c'è da qui andiamo a cercarlo e va bene
questa volta dove sei
ho detto che mi arrendo
mi arrendo non mi ero qua vedete si era
mimetizzato in mezzo ai pupazzi cooper
che manchino voleva continuamente salire
lo saprà capire
scusami parli non avevo capito no a
tutti di giocare contro di me che mi ha
imbrogliato così e io non ho scusato
berlino perché in genere lui va a
rosicchiare questa pianta poverina
infatti a qualche foglio un po
rinsecchita se riuscito a vederla il
2010 che sta per vincere
io pensavo che berlino vuole tendere
rosicchiare la pianta nuovamente noi che
ci possa evitare nascosta dire pupazzi
là dietro
lo sposo di parchi tale padre in cina
diventata perché stai qui mi vuoi dire
qualcosa ha dentro
poiché guarda qua dentro
merlino mi stai dicendo che devo aprire
a cadetta giorni non vuole stare con te
ecco perché ti trovo se non è vero
abbiamo stretto un accordo segreto une
berlino dopo dirottate le crocchette le
crocchette come d'accordo
bravo bravo berlino sicura opinione
ma non è tutto io mi sono spiaccicata
dentro quel sa armadio pensando che non
mi avresti trovato inverso e berlino era
lì da lì dietro tutto il tempo perché
non è vero che il bravo perché senza
l'aiuto di berlino non sarebbe riuscito
a trovarmi tempo
da rivedere i piani foglio di viaggio ma
anche questo mio cavallo è ragionato
questo bisogno
ecco l'ultimo allora cosa aspettate 22
metà invece vediamo questo sì qual
astori spera histories team arriva da
dietro che strizza l'occhio di un sacco
zuccherino sfondino se volete che
giochiamo un'altra volta lasciate un bel
mi piace ea 30 mila mi piace faremo la
seconda parte magari in un'area diversa
declino che ci cercano di gioco che si
sarebbe tre bombe minuti per carni
italiani tanto bravo marino che mi ha
aiutato dopo ti darò tutte le crocchette
tate coccolino non è giusto io ho aperto
dal padulo vi ricordo che potete trovare
water squillino edicola in allegato alla
rivista se li prendete fateci sapere se
avete preso l'uomo o il pesce con tutti
e due eliminati la grillina 4 per
dell'innse quindi care per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione